alright first of all let me give a shout
out to the Museum of the Bible in in DC
my wife and I went there on Saturday and
we thought it was wonderful much bigger
more elaborate than I thought it was
gonna be I was picturing like a church
basement with maybe some Bibles and and
some paintings and like some dioramas
made by the 8th grade
Sunday school or something but it's
definitely much much more than that
there is it's just it's a massive place
with a great mix of historic artifacts
and and interactive kinds of
presentations including a lifelike model
of Nazareth which you can go through and
go through the different houses and
visit the temple and and all that kind
of it's just very impressive so I
definitely recommend it affordable to
what was not impressive however I have
to mention because we were in DC when
the snowstorm hit we stayed overnight my
kids were my parents watched our kids so
we could go with music in the Bible we
stayed overnight in DC and we woke up
the next morning and there was like 6
inches of snow on the ground
yet somehow half of the roads in the
city hadn't been plowed yet including
295 which is a massive highway that's
that that connects DC to Baltimore and
it had been reduced down to 1 unplowed
Lane with all of these abandoned
vehicles strewn all over the place it
looked like something out of The Walking
Dead and this is not because of the
shutdown you should know you cannot
blame this on the shutdown this is just
how it is in DC DC has never figured out
how to deal with snowstorms even though
they're in the Northeast and they've
gotten or at least the mid-atlantic
region they get snowstorms every year ok
DC has existed as a city for 230 years
and so that means it's probably gotten
what like maybe 450 or 500 snowstorms
throughout its existence and through
those 500 snowstorms it still has not
learned to expect snowstorms or what to
do when snow lands on the ground and so
there's just confusion and incompetence
but what else can you expect from these
but confusion and incompetence all right
I wanted to mention a story related to
the Bible that's going nuts on The Daily
wire right now it's gotten like 160,000
shares or something in a day written by
Frank camp
it's about pastor Justin Hoke of Trinity
Bible Presbyterian Church in in weed
California and kind of an unfortunate
name for a for a town especially in
California named weed he's now lost his
position as pastor because of a message
that he put on a church sign and the
sign says or said Bruce Jenner is still
a man homosexuality is still a sin the
culture may change the Bible does not
now he says he was inspired to create
the sign after seeing that remember that
viral video of the of the guy losing his
mind at a store because the cashier
called him sir rather than man
so for pastor Hoke he saw that videos
kind of like the proverbial straw
breaking the camel's back and he wrote
this he put this sign up as a form of
protest against the insanity and madness
in our culture now we can have a
discussion about whether or not a church
sign is really the most effective forum
to have these kinds of discussions but
we can't have a discussion about whether
the message on the sign was doctrinally
and scripturally orthodox because of
course it was without question the
message communicates an indisputable
Christian truth and when I say
indisputable Christian truth I mean that
it is a truth that no Christian can
dispute if you're not a Christian you
can try to dispute it but if you are a
Christian you you really you literally
cannot because in order to dispute it
you would have to toss out the Bible and
once you've done that then you're not a
Christian anymore so in order to
spute that christian that homosexuality
is a sin or that God makes us male or
female in order to dispute that you
would have to take the Bible and
basically like toss it into that fire I
have behind me but if you're going do
that then as I said you you have given
up the basis for your faith so you could
not possibly retain your faith while
doing that but still there was a protest
people are upset about the sign and the
pastor says that it was communicated to
him that some of the church elders and
many of the church members wanted him to
leave and would themselves leave if he
did not demanded that he leave and so
ultimately he decided that he had no
choice now I personally look I'm not
gonna make judgment calls for him and
his family he had to decide to do what
was best for him and his family I kind
of wish he would have said okay well if
you want to leave the church go ahead
and if we only have five people left in
the church then that's what it's going
to be because if you don't if you're not
on board with biblical truth then it's
better for you to look I'm not gonna
leave because you don't support biblical
truth you can leave I'm not going to I
wish he had said that he chose not to
and and he ended up leaving and all of
that because he put something on a sign
that can be found over and over again in
the Bible itself a couple of other
points about that the sign was protested
not just by people in the church but
also by Pete other people in the
community like community members who
were not members of the church
presumably not Christian but this is
interesting because you know the left
has always claimed that it has no
problem with our religion as long as we
don't force it on them and as long as we
keep it in the church now I personally
have a problem with the idea that our
faith is supposed to be kept in a church
building and away from the public square
because that's not what that is not
consistent with the protections that we
are afforded in the First Amendment
that's not what it means to
a free American that's also not what it
means to be a Christian as Christians we
are not supposed to keep our truth the
truth in a church building we were
supposed to declare it to the world but
in this case okay it was it was on
church property on a church sign so why
are you protesting in that case if if
the left was really sincere about Noah
you know we're not trying to stop you
from from worshipping your God and from
following your religion just just just
you know don't don't throw it in our
face well we see yet again that they're
not serious about that you know that's
just something that they said so that we
would accept with each kind of step down
the slippery slope they're always going
to say oh no no you know we're just
gonna go here and no further no no
you're fine look we're not trying it no
no we were just got it we just want to
take this one more step and then that's
it well we promise okay we promised but
it never works out that way because
ultimately the left hates biblical
Christianity it despises it it does not
think that Christianity has any right to
exist and and its ultimate goal is to
see Christianity destroyed I mean that's
just there's no way around it that's
that's very obvious second thing so okay
that deals with the non-christians who
are protesting but if you are a
Christian and you don't like the sexual
morality of Christianity if you don't
like the the the message of sexual
morality that you get from from
Christianity which is a morality that
applies to everyone by the way not just
homosexuals okay so this is not just a
thing where if you're a homosexual you
have to abide by these rules of chastity
know that this goes for everybody we're
all we're all subject to it but if you
don't like it
you have a few options right you can
leave you can denounce the faith
renounce the faith I should say and say
I'm not Christian more I'm leaving you
could do that or you could stay and you
could struggle to abide by these
teachings as difficult as it is and
you're going to probably fail and fall
and stumble along the way and so there's
gonna be you're gonna be repenting and
going back to God there's gonna be a lot
of Prayer and all of that so that that's
that's another option or you could stay
but then basically personally ignore
these teachings in your personal life
and do what you want and then take it up
with God later now I don't recommend
that third path I don't recommend the
first path either of leaving although if
you have to choose between you know door
one two or three and you're not going to
choose door two which is staying and
struggling and trying to abide by the
teachings and you're left with only one
or three I would think one is better
than three
you know just leaving the church
completely is better than staying and
committing to this path of being a
hypocrite and a fraud but those are you
know three potential paths you could
take the path that you really can't take
the path that doesn't make sense and
that is impossible is to stay and then
try to insist that the morality of
Christianity be changed or amended or
something like that you know because
Christianity is not a it's not a
democracy it's not a it's not a
political movement it's not a you know a
governing administration where you can
petition for change and you can you know
hope that it keeps up with the times or
whatever that's not what it is it is a
general unchanging truth it cannot be
changed so that other option of staying
and trying to change it and trying to
get rid of that teaching in this
teaching in that teaching that just
doesn't make sense alright um staying in
this general realm I wanted to follow up
on a conversation from from last week
last Friday we talked about mega church
pastor Andy Stanley who recently made
headlines yet again for insisting that
the Old Testament including the Ten
Commandments do not apply to Christians
actually as I mentioned on Friday
Stanley's been on this crusade against
what he calls the Jewish Scriptures for
a while now and he is in the past over
the last year too he has been urging
Christians to unhitch that's his phrase
unhitched themselves from the Old
Testament and he has declared that the
first three or four dozen books of the
Bible should not be a quote go to source
regarding any behavior and he's also
said inaccurately that the early church
unhitched itself from the quote world
view and quote value system of the Old
Testament he has said that those
Christians who still strive to follow
the moral teachings of the Old Testament
are standing on a quote Old Testament
house of cards which could come crashing
down at any moment in various interviews
he has appeared to really kind of be
embarrassed by the Old Testament and he
said that the Old Testament books are
disturbing and violent he says that you
know to led many people to lose their
faith and so what he says is we should
just leave it out the Old Testament
should be quote left out of the
apologetic argument those again are his
words left out now of course Jesus
did not leave it out I mean Jesus quoted
from the Old Testament or for back in
those days it would have just been
scripture Jesus quoted from Scripture
all the time he was constantly quoting
from Scripture that's one of the things
when you actually sit down and read the
books and I'm not sure if Annie Stanley
has has ever done that based on what he
based on is what he says I he does not
appear to have any biblical knowledge at
all but if you actually sit down and
read it you're gonna find that Jesus
it's constantly quoting what we call the
Old Testament quoting it authoritative
Lee as in saying it's in Scripture so
you should care about this you should be
following this okay and he is he is
using it as a he is appealing to it
citing it all the time now when Stanley
has been confronted with that argument
he's suggested that well yeah Jesus
talks about Scripture but we don't
really know what that means and it might
not necessarily mean the Old Testament
text as we know them no yes yes that is
what it means there aren't any other
scriptures that he could be that he
could be referring to especially because
a lot of times he gives you chapter and
verse he's gonna actually quote them
himself so like for instance when Jesus
gives us the what Stanley apparently and
some Christians think are completely new
Commandments love the Lord God love your
neighbor when Jesus gives us those
Commandments and Stanley says well those
are the new Commandments that you know
love God that's the one commandment all
the rest are just tossed out don't pay
attention to them well when Jesus is
doing that he is quoting the Old
Testament
those are Commandments that are in
Deuteronomy and inlet of Leviticus
Jesus obviously knew that so this was
now they are new in the sense of you
might say new
the emphasized you could or something
like that but they are not actually new
he is quoting Old Testament so so and he
Stanley says unhitch ourselves from the
Old Testament meanwhile Jesus is saying
the greatest commandment is this one
right here in the Old Testament so that
is it just doesn't work the two so
you've got what Andy Stanley is saying
you have what Jesus Christ is saying
they're saying two completely different
things and then you have to decide are
you gonna listen to Andy Stanley or
Jesus Christ
me personally I'm gonna listen to Jesus
Christ if you decide that Andy Stanley
is your guy then go for it but as I said
that's not Christianity that's a
completely different religion now in the
last week he wrote an article
criticizing Christians who erect
monuments to the ten commandments he
says that the Ten Commandments don't
apply to us again those are his words
they don't apply don't kill don't steal
don't commit adultery Andy Stanley says
doesn't apply to us doesn't apply you
know whatever he says again his words
Christians are not required to obey any
of the commandments found in the first
part of their Bible you don't have to
obey any of it the first commandment the
first command that God gives humankind
be fruitful and multiply I guess we
don't have to don't don't listen to that
one either I mean the the very first
things that Jesus did that God is saying
to to mankind
I mean God throughout the Old Testaments
is constantly speaking to mankind and
and speaking giving these moral commands
these moral truths and these are not
arbitrary commands God does not speak
arbitrary he is talking about a moral
truth that is woven into the fabric of
human existence so it's not like when
God says don't commit adultery don't
murder he it's it's not like he just
decided randomly that yeah you shouldn't
do that but this is part of reality
itself
now why according to Stanley is it so
crucial for for Christians to reject or
as he says disengage with or unhitch
themselves from the Old Testament he
says well because in part the Old
Testament has been used throughout
history to to justify all kinds of
atrocities and he and he uses the same
ones that atheist used the Crusades the
Inquisition he says that that came that
that came about because of an
overemphasis on the Old Testament which
is just wrong on so many levels
now he's betraying not only a biblical
illiteracy but a general historical
illiteracy and actually the Crusades for
one thing happened as a result of 400
years of Muslim aggression and the
Inquisition's were an attempt by the
church to put a legal process in place
for those accused of heresy as opposed
to the summary executions carried out by
angry villagers which had been the
policy before the church intervened but
putting all that aside here's my point
I already issued my rebuttal to this
heresy which as I said is really just a
reheated version of Marcion ISM which is
a heresy from like nineteen hundred
years ago
Marcion was a guy who said said
basically the same thing Old Testament
doesn't apply to us that's for Jews it's
not for us we don't have to listen to it
same same basic thing but as we were
talking about this this discussion
you know prompted a lot of interesting
feedback and I would say as an
unscientific estimate probably 75 to 80
percent of the feedback that I received
was extremely critical of stanley's
position it basically in agreement with
me a lot of people made additional
points that I hadn't thought over
brought up so that was interesting
but there was also a solid probably 20
or 25 percent of the people that I've
heard from over the weekend who
passionately agree with Stanley and also
insist that the Old Testament is
effectively useless and all of the
commandments given in those books are
now irrelevant we don't have to listen
to them and have to follow them
God apparently was not speaking
eternally when he gave when he's when he
spoke these moral truths they these
moral truths had a had a an expiration
date and these Christians have just
decided now God never said the
expiration date but these Christians
have decided that they did the one thing
that these people do when arguing that
the first two thirds of the Bible are
now basically pointless and that God's
commands are actually just like symbolic
suggestions the one thing they do is you
know they'll find a verse they'll find
one verse in Scripture usually in the
epistles and then they'll hinge their
whole argument on this one line
completely removed from context
completely isolated and they use this
one line to basically render almost
every other line in the scripture in
Scripture moot so they grab on the they
searched desperately for one sentence
that seems to kind of support their
position they grab on to this one
sentence and they say you see all we
need is this one set we don't even need
the rest of the Bible we have this one
sentence right here that's all it's all
right there we don't need anything else
now this isn't something that people
just do with this argument this is
something that Christians often do in in
general in any theological argument and
it's one of the worst things it's one of
the most insidious
things in in the church today and that's
really what I want to talk about is it's
called proof texting which which is
another word for that is another phrase
term for that is cherry-picking but I
think proof texting is a better more
more specific term proof texting is when
you you want to prove a certain
theological position that you've taken
usually it's going to be a position that
you've already taken okay importantly
here you already have the position and
now you're going to go in the Bible and
find a
justification for it so that's what you
do you you have your position in mind in
this case let's say for instance your
position is the Old Testament doesn't
matter we don't have to follow anything
that it says you've got that in your
mind and then you you know you flip over
open the Bible even you're just looking
you're like give me one sentence all I
need is one sentence that seems to sort
of support that and you go searching
desperately for it although usually
you're not going to have a physical
Bible you're gonna be doing with Google
looking for that one sentence that seems
to fit in and and once you find that
sentence context be damned you're gonna
hang your whole theology on it this is a
very common thing especially these days
because of the internet the internet
makes it so easy to do you know you
could even plug in to Google and once
you have your position in mind you could
even just Google biblical support for
exposition and then you're gonna find
someone somewhere has made a list and
you find the verse and boom there it is
that that's all of your biblical
research that's all you need to do and
so for this argument a lot of people
cited Hebrews 813 which says by calling
this covenant new he has made the first
one obsolete and what is obsolete and
outdated will soon disappear now okay
sure yeah you take that take that verse
take it in isolation you know it all by
itself and you seem to have found
yourself pretty good proof right that's
what and that's what proof texting is
it's easy to do when you're proof
texting you could find proof for pretty
much any position whatsoever when you're
proof texting and in this case so you
find it in Hebrews you find one line you
find one sentence by the way written by
an anonymous author we don't even know
who wrote it we have no idea who wrote
Hebrews now that doesn't mean that it's
not legitimate I'm not calling into
question whether Hebrews should have
been included in the Canon even though
some church fathers did call that into
question but I'm not I'm just
highlighting the absurdity here okay the
absurdity of using one sentence one line
from an anonymous author all the way in
the back of
Bible to basically nullify everything
that came before it it is an absurd
ridiculous thing to do and the thing is
if this is just a general good general
rule for reading your Bible if you come
across a sentence which would seem to
nullify almost everything else you've
read in the book then it's it's likely
that your interpretation is wrong if if
the line made the first one obsolete
really means what Andy Stanley thinks
that Christians as he says are not
required to obey anything at all that
was written in the first two-thirds of
their Bible then why did the people who
compiled the Bible even include the
first two-thirds of it why did they why
did they just give us the the Gospels
and some of the epistles and then leave
the Old Testament to the Jews Andy
Stanley says what's the Jewish scripture
it's not for us okay but why is it put
in the same book for us the people who
compiled the Bible they put it all
together why did they do that why did
they just leave it for the Old Testament
for the Jews and say that though don't
worry about that part of it that's not
for you I mean you could go read it if
you want to but don't worry that's what
Andy Stanley is saying but that's not
the position that the writers and
compilers of Scripture
took so you have to look at everything
in context is what I'm saying you have
to justify your theological positions
with the entirety of Scripture not just
one sentence because if we're doing the
one sentence game if we're doing the
proof texting game then as I said I can
find proof I can find biblical support
for any position and I really mean any
position starting with the position that
the earth is flat we've talked about
that in the past if you're doing proof
text thing I could easily find you a
couple of verses that would really seem
to indicate that the earth is flat or I
think more troublingly and more and more
you know in a more relevant way if I'm
isolating sentences removing them from
context I could certainly justify any
heresy
that has ever been drunk dreamt up so
Andy Stanley justifies Marcion ISM but
you could do it with any heresy Arianism
the heresy that Christ is a created
being not eternal not equal with the
father not divine in the same sense as
God the Father well I could isolate many
sentences in Scripture that would seem
to fit that bill how about this one why
do you call me good no one is good but
God alone if you're looking at that
sentence by itself completely isolated
from everything around it well then it
that would seem to be you say wow what
was Jesus saying he's not God here what
about adoptionism okay the belief that
Jesus Christ was adopted as the Son of
God at some certain point in his life
but was not the Son of God eternally so
you could I mean adoption Asst
adoptionism that was a thing in the
early days of the church and the
adoption is they had their verses that
they could point to one of the verses
one of the stories that they used is
that the stories of Jesus's baptism when
God announces this is my beloved son and
so many adoption is an they argued that
Jesus became the son of God in that
moment and they say well God didn't
announce this you know at Jesus's birth
this wasn't announced that any other but
this was announced at the baptism okay
so he was adopted in a moment there
there you go there's all the proof I
need if I'm just looking at that story
by itself as if it existed on its own
without anything else around it how
about docetism the belief that Jesus was
not really flesh and blood and was
actually a kind of like a phantasm or or
a hallucination a hologram basically
projected from heaven
well Colossians does say after all that
Jesus was the image of the invisible God
now you wouldn't I mean it's I mean it
seems odd to say of a physical
flesh-and-blood human that they are an
image of something else right so knows
and I could go on but you get the idea
now the fake scriptural support for
docetism that I just mentioned is kind
of weak admittedly I'm actually not sure
what what Scripture is that dosent is
used to support their position I'm
thinking they probably use some of the
Gnostic Gospels that weren't included in
the Canon like like the Gospel of Thomas
or Gospel of Judas or Mary or whatever
else but arianism now you can find some
very compelling passages like the one
that I cited no one is good but God why
do you call me good and you can find
others that on their own seem like
interesting pieces of evidence in in
favor of Arianism in fact the Gospels
don't make Christ's divinity completely
explicit until you get to John's Gospel
which was the last one written you know
like John's Gospel wasn't written until
until probably the year ninety or so so
a knowledgeable proponent of arianism
all they need to do is toss out that one
book the last gospel written all they
gotta do is just toss that one out and
or just or just make the whole thing
symbolic symbolic eyes which isn't a
word all of John's Gospel and say yeah
well you know that's just theological
symbolic you know you know take that
literally
and then maybe toss out a few of the
epistles and once you've done that
everything else else everything else
kind of falls into place and and boom
you've got Arianism you know you've
proved it that's what happens when you
don't look at the totality of Scripture
when you don't look at the overall point
being made when you don't look at the
overall story being told and that's also
what happens by the way when you just go
into the Bible yourself and interpret it
completely on your own you know when you
just pick up a Bible haphazardly and
just flip through it and just come up
with your own interpretations for
everything that you read paying no mind
at all to the theological tradition
of Christianity or to what the you know
great teachers and apologists have said
or to what the Church Fathers said I
mean the thing is the guys who actually
helped to compile and translate the
Bible guys like like Saint Jerome for
instance you know they'll tell you what
they thought about some of these issues
all you have to go these guys they wrote
about these issues and you can go and
you can read what they had to say
they'll give you their own theological
interpretations of these things and I
would think that their opinion probably
should carry some weight right
considering they're the ones who gave us
the Bible we wouldn't have a Bible if it
wasn't for them they are the instruments
the instruments that God chose to use to
compile and translate these documents
now that doesn't make their personal
theological opinions infallible it
doesn't mean that we have to agree with
everything that they said st. Agustin
one of the most brilliant Christians to
ever live I think that if you really
want to know the Bible and understand
your own religion you got to read some
of Augustan but he had opinions that I
think were not only wrong but
repulsively wrong like he thought that
all babies who aren't baptized go to
hell okay I absolutely reject that
opinion I don't accept that from him but
that doesn't mean that I'm just going to
toss a gusted out completely and say I
this opinion doesn't matter but that's
the there is this kind of aggressive
ignorant that's very common among some
Christians today where that's what they
do they say you know it doesn't matter
what any of those guys had to say now it
doesn't matter I don't care what anyone
says I'm just gonna pick up the Bible
myself and I'm gonna come up with my own
interpretation for all these things
because I'm smart enough to figure all
this out on my own but you know the
problem is the people who say that they
say you know what I'm just doing the
song yeah I don't need any of those guys
st. jerome agustin who needs a Aquinas I
don't need them I the church fathers who
cares the people who say that and who
act
like you know I'm not gonna appeal to
anyone else's opinion it's all about my
own opinion what inevitably ends up
happening is that they do end up
trusting someone else's opinion you know
because they're too lazy to do the work
on their own they aren't actually gonna
sit there and read the whole Bible and
come up with their own interpretations
for everything I mean I don't recommend
doing that but at least if you actually
did that it means you're reading the
whole Bible and you're putting some work
and effort and thought into it so you
know there is some positive maybe that
could come out of it but the people who
have that as I said aggressively
ignorant self-centered sort of mentality
arrogant mentality to where they think
that they're smart and wise enough to
figure all this out on their own and so
that 2,000 years
of theological teaching and
interpretation is irrelevant as far as
they're concerned what ends up happening
is that is is is that they don't want to
do the work so they're going to latch on
to some person who comes along and
offers a very simplistic very easy to
understand very self-serving
interpretation and they're gonna latch
on to that guy and say you know yeah
I'll go with him so you have some
Christians who you know are gonna latch
on to Andy Stanley and they're gonna say
you know well yeah I'm gonna go with
Andy Stanley all the rest of those guys
over there the entire history I mean all
the most the most brilliant minds that
have ever existed in the history of
Christianity I'm gonna ignore all of
them and I'm gonna go with Andy Stanley
if I have to if I you know I've got Andy
Stanley on one hand and then I've got
like Saint Jerome and Agustin over here
I'm gonna go with Stanley yeah he's my
guy that's what ends up happening is is
is these people are just kind of
vulnerable they leave themselves very
spiritually and sort of theologically
vulnerable and then they get they get
they get plucked up by heretics who are
maybe give
did speakers and can offer them a
dumbed-down
boiled down as I said self-centered
self-serving interpretation and that's
what they're going to go with so as much
as they say no it's all about me and
Jesus personal relationship it's not
about listening to what anyone else says
yeah but it's it ends up not really
being me and G it ends up being you
Jesus and Andy Stanley or you Jesus and
and Joel Osteen or something like that
that's what it ends up you Jesus and
Joyce Meyer you know that's what it ends
up being you end up with this personal
sort of Trinity only there's one except
there's only one person in that Trinity
that belongs in a Trinity and that's
Jesus and the other two no all right I
guess we'll we'll leave it there
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed